So starting off with hand painted materials,
let's talk about how we might go about creating a material
set up for hand painted materials.
So to set this material up,
you just need to first add a landscape layer blend node
into a material, which you can see here.
You can see the image on the left-hand side as well.
And so this node will specify which layers
and the colors of layers that you want
in your landscape material.
So you can actually add more inputs here
by pressing the plus button.
And so for this example, we'll be using three layers.
We'll use a grass color, a dirt color and a rock color.
And then just so you can name them the relevant blends.
And then when we actually get to our landscape,
we can apply the material that we've just created
to the landscape.
So we want to open up the landscape tools
and then click on the paint option.
And then we should have these three entries
that you previously created,
which is the grass, the dirt and the rock.
So if we press the plus icon here next to the layer
and select weighted blend layer,
which the brackets is normal there,
we can save the new created asset
in a location in your content browser.
It'll suggest somewhere.
So you can go ahead and save it there
unless you'd like to save it somewhere different.
But if you also look at the weighted blend layers,
it allows you to paint on top of layers
so that the layers blend correctly.
So we can use this when we want to blend,
say rock into dirt, for example.
So a non-weighted blend layer
would allow you to replace the layers
as you paint over them.
So you can use this when you want to have,
say snow covering rocks or dirt.
So just think about whether you want to
use the weighted blend layers
or the non-weighted blend layers
and the difference, as we said,
weighted blend means that you can blend more easily,
say from rock to dirt.
Non-weighted means that you might have snow covering rock
or something like this.
And then we can repeat that process
for the dirt and rock layers.
And then when we're done,
we'll be able to hand paint the landscape
by selecting the layer from the list
and then just painting it directly in the viewport.